hey guys Ryan the right here and Dan
Stan's glasses here we are gonna watch
the blood-borne gameplay trailer
mmm-hmm and now it's long so let's not
[ __ ] around then an edit internet dinner
PlayStation start on the Japan studio
just remains I'm sorry I don't want the
sugar her developing a
oh boy
whoever's playing as this guy's really
slow he's just taking all in man oh yeah
every detail so bad I just gotta go oh
wow he really sound like he was dying
hey say you look pretty [ __ ] badass
hunter bullet you'll need it for hunting
I wasn't hard yeah
I assume it's they're making this easy
Oh Rocco they got the attention of the
one do I like that it's bloody but I
wish there was more detail today
oh it's still development anything that
was it yeah
oh alright alright don't ask and we're
done
host it's kind of like Mortal Kombat
where they just bleed
nope yeah you don't want to go there
ma'am maybe you do [ __ ] is playing I
know right hey sky doesn't seem like he
knows much about the game Oh God good
luck tied up again now dammit
should be the rest of the gameplay truth
yeah we're not yeah this is a real jump
cutting game I mean the game looks cool
but what are we doing here
it's like you just go around slashing
people okay different not gonna life I
was behind the controller I'd be really
scared oh yeah dude oh hey okay
got another one get a friend oh dear bro
oh I guess he's fine
I didn't win the [ __ ] point
Buehrle fighting Z um mom's monsters I
know but like the bad guess zombies
there's chicks and rapper there you're
gonna go ahead and yeah teabagging yep
didn't see bag Jack Tripper mistake son
what the [ __ ] how did you not see him
okay who's in the wheelchair
oh damn it's kinda like running and
walking running walking kind of looking
left and right what are we doing man
let us help you oh [ __ ]
and ooh
Oh fun
how far he goes to beat that I don't
know he's not in tune well
songs sound really sweet
and
what that gameplay sure there was a
little a little bit like we're kind of
in you're like oh yeah when we're
watching you think the game was cool
the game was badass now the game looks
cool but honestly as far as the actual
like attacking stuff go it all looks
kind of the same though that's the
disappoint let's say you press the same
button and you just does these moves I
like when you can mix it up yeah if I
remember correctly these are from the
guys that did Dark Souls and you can
really kind of see some of the layout
for that so it is a little bit more
slower and yeah but not it looks a
little faster than Dark Souls but man
that was not good no it does a trailer
it was a generator that was all ya know
like the graphics and everything are
awesome it looks great the music was
awesome yeah boom and I'll I love the
imagery like a lot the answer is great
the designs are amazing but the gameplay
itself kind of looks like you do the
same slashing lose to everything yeah
well yeah yes and no yeah I mean there's
gonna be a lot more strategy I imagine
it being a lot more stressful when
you're playing yeah I might have just
been the trailer to be honest tonight
yeah honestly I think it's like
everything just like the trailers like
let's just cut around
yeah like random stuff alright guys well
thanks for recommending that trailer if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects dan has a
gaming channel that's right
games you can check that out I do games
recently passed a thousand subs Congrats
dance hey I did it
you helped me do it yeah let's uh let's
get some shoutouts you know get back to
the community by shouting at her name
out snow dog moolah hey Ryan
I like a shout-out please also Murray
seems like a pretty cool human being I
guess I think she is snow dog moolah
what does that mean kind of calling a
snow dog millionaire slow dog
millionaire snowy snow dog millionaire
that's pretty cool that it that would be
cool I'd be cool maybe the sequel to
snow dogs Slumdog Millionaire it would
be a hybrid film or to me the Husky hair
try to it what's a billionaire yeah man
you totally get a shout out shout out to
you snow dog Mew
I'm proud of you you stay in there and
stay classy hope you win a million
dollars of you and a million dollars on
that game show my friend Jeff on Lee hmm
i watch your videos all the time
you're the best and I thank you for
making videos every day and
congratulations for the Oh Veronica
everyone's talking about Veronica uh-huh
gee I wonder why no maybe cuz I keep
talking about hey hey please get a
shout-out and you Veronica should kiss
on the videos I think everyone would get
pretty sick of that you know people
already sick of me mentioning I got a
girlfriend so the fact if I kiss Roenick
on camera would probably just annoy more
people mmm I mean benefits for me don't
get me wrong but you guys won't why you
get bored cuz Veronica and I it was the
build-up of the tension you know the
romantic sexual tension you know but
then such this is the you know but like
after Jim and Pam got together it was
good for a couple seasons yeah there's a
show going down
don't the show go down it's like the
whole ideas don't keep them together
because when you get together show my
losses miss you need to stop now
just stop it we're gonna be its channel
better
thanks Siobhan Lee for the inspiration I
will take it into consideration like
appreciate you leading me there my
friend do you stay classy dark side Mika
love the vids and the jokes great work
Ryan and you have a beautiful and
talented girlfriend brings Veronica
shoutout yeah thank you for the
compliment my girlfriend is talented and
beautiful she hahaha caught myself
before I said anything not gonna get in
trouble tonight baby
this is about you though [ __ ] Tamika
had done what does it say dark side Mika
sorry
I like cyanide alright dark side Mika
what is your dark side exactly what does
it consist of you is it like casual like
oh yeah be casual - my dark side like
I'm depressed and [ __ ] with her every
now and then I chokehold someone to kill
someone by get over it half don't need
to be a pessimist to get through in the
dark side I think it's the best shot you
can get darkside MIGA yeah